Hey look here at the October's YouTube
channel and today I am making this beer
it's gonna be awesome
[Music]
alright I'm really excited for this
project this is the first beer project
I've ever done and to start I'm going to
take this piece of leaf spring steel
here and I'm gonna cut out the rough
profile of both the spearhead and the
spearhead tang once we get that cut out
then we're gonna stick it in the Forge
and we're going to finish up shaping it
but I'm gonna start with an angle
grinder
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well I finished the first spearhead and
it's it's beautiful I really think this
thing is beautiful it's just it's got
imperfections and character and hammer
marks and it just looks amazing we're
going to set this aside and I'm gonna
start working on the second spearhead
for the second part of the spearhead I'm
going to use this masonry stake it's a
36 inch stake but it's a little bit
thicker than I want so what I'm thinking
is I'm going to end up drawing it out
once I've drawn it out and stretched it
it'll be the right length and diameter
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the Sun is setting it's getting dark and
raining my wrist is jelly so I think
it's time to call it for a day we've
made some awesome progress I'll pick
this up again
okay so what I'm hoping to do is I need
to stretch up this material right here
sit it out a little bit
let's clean it up make it look a little
bit nicer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so I trimmed off this and now you got
that not too bad right now all right
I've got the rough metal work done on
this spear so now I need to get the
shaft put together and I have this piece
of African mahogany that I'm gonna use
for the shaft it's a beautiful piece of
woods got some great colors rich colors
that are gonna just really pop once they
get this polished but you can see it's
quite a thick piece of lumber so I'm
gonna cut a strip that's as wide as this
piece of wood is thick and I'm gonna
make it about Oh 36 40 inches long not
100% sure quite yet but I'm gonna start
off with this large long rectangular
piece then I'm gonna have to turn it
into a tapered round shaft by hand so I
don't own table saws and I don't have
any power tools that would do this job
so I'm gonna use a handsaw
the biggest problem with the hand side
isn't the effort it's the accuracy it's
hard to get a straight line unless
you're used to it and I'm you know not
that great at it so we'll see what
happens now the reason why it these
Spears are short I'm not making them
five six feet long it's because they're
meant to be thrown and the longer the
spear the more likely you are to bend or
break it when it sticks into something
so if you have a 48 inch you know 50
inch long spear and you penetrate
something with it it's it's more likely
to bend under its own weight so shorter
is better to a point so 36 inches is
what I'm going to start with we'll see
how that goes
well it looks like today is arm day baby
oh well this is why I do all these
projects in the fall and winter whoo
it's 40 degrees out I'm sweating like a
pig imagine doing this in a 90 degree
heat I be dying oh my are you uh are you
using that piece of rebar on the car
okay Nathan yeah don't don't hit the car
with with the metal it hurts the car
okay you think that's gonna make a good
spear yeah me too
well there you go 36 inches of African
mahogany and it's pretty square not too
bad all right I got these lines that I
drew on the edges to give me a kind of a
guide and I'm gonna go and take all
these corners off with the angle grinder
[Music]
alright guys so not so bad so far
got a octagon here and it's already
starting to feel Brown feel good in the
hand I'm going to hit the eight corners
of this octagon with the angle grinder
and then I'm gonna start smoothing it
out and getting the whole thing round
then we got to start putting the taper
in both ends there you go not too bad
it's not perfectly round but feels feels
good in the hand and once I hand sand
this it'll really look look pretty round
plus I'm gonna put a taper into it so
that's okay it's a work in progress but
really pleased with how it looks so far
alright so I've got the dowel rounded
out but now I need to taper the ends as
you can see it fits on not quite right
so once I taper that down should work
pretty well
are you gonna tell you I was at work all
today just thinking about this project
just itching to get back here and work
on this thing so I'm pretty jazzed now
one thing I did notice is that the
length of my GoPro is smoked looks like
some of the sparks from the angle
grinder melted little pock marks all
over the lid so hopefully this video
quality isn't too terrible but today I
am gonna get this thing mounted and what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna drill a couple
holes and put pins in this to try to
keep it together so we'll see if that
works all right I got my a cheapo Harbor
Freight drill press here and I'm gonna
put a hole with a quarter inch drill bit
right there through the middle then I'm
gonna try to punch one here and one
there as well
all right so now I'm gonna put it in a
little dowel and cut it off right about
there that'll be our first pin look at
that this is so rough looking I mean
nobody on earth would think that this
was manufactured in a factory but I love
it this way I this it just looks so cool
now a lot of you guys may be at home
going oh you didn't heat treat it you
didn't heat treat it yeah that's
absolutely right I did not heat treat
this heat treating is to make something
harder okay but it also makes it more
brittle and this is a javelin okay
it's not a razor it's a javelin and when
this thing sticks into something it puts
a lot of force on this especially right
here at the neck and I don't want it
snapping I mean this is this is like a
pry bar that you throw at somebody so I
don't want it to be SuperDuper hard I
want it to to bend a little bit and so
softer more bendable metal is ideal with
this but the other end of the javelin
this part of the spear this part is for
cutting it's like a sword okay and so I
am gonna heat treat this and treat it
like a knife all right so now I'm gonna
sand the shaft let's start with 80 grit
then work my way up to one twenty two
twenty four hundred eight hundred
thousand fifteen hundred mm and then
like six thousand grit and then so I'm
gonna polish this with sandpaper
[Music]
look at that that's just from sanding
the wood feels and looks like it's been
lacquered but now it's just been
polished polished with sandpaper now I'm
just gonna take a wet towel some water
on it and just get all the sawdust off
it and take what little linseed oil I
have left all right that's just wiping
it down with some linseed oil get a
beautiful wood
well sanded and it looks gorgeous well
I'm really happy with the progress I
made today
this looks awesome but it's late
I got work tomorrow so pick this up
tomorrow oh yeah got a nice point on the
javel in there do you feel in charge
[Laughter]
oh I have got to put an edge on this
I've got to heat treat it and I've got
to sharpen it and then I've got to mount
it
[Music]
all right now I've got a ground edge on
this I'm gonna heat up the forge I'm
gonna heat this piece of metal up to
about cherry red Kanna straw yellow and
then I'm gonna take it and I'm gonna
dunk it in this PVC pipe full of motor
oil I'm gonna quench it in the motor oil
and that will harden it up and put a
knife's edge on it let's give this thing
heat it up
[Music]
yeah I don't care how many times you do
that that's cool
[Music]
there you go there's the the blade after
the oil quench looks pretty darn good it
doesn't look like I melted any part of
it which is a real danger in these coal
fires that you accidentally melt the
edges or melt the tip while you're
waiting for this Center to heat up well
I've got an edge on it but it's not that
sharp I've got this about as sharp as a
hatchet not as sharp as a knife I'm
gonna be attaching this to a spear and
throwing it around so a little bit of a
safety issue there I can always turn
around and sharpen it more later but for
right now I think this is good enough
okay this is the part I am most nervous
about I have got to drill a hole a
perfectly straight hole to mount that
other spearhead the best I can do is use
the bubble on the end of my drill and
kind of freehand it a little bit first
I'm gonna check this to make sure it's
level and if this is level and then this
is level and then I ball it hopefully
I'll get a straight hole well the hole
isn't quite right so I'm gonna go and
just knock some of the corners off this
tang here I want it to slide in pretty
decent before it starts to really get
pressure I could hammer it in but then
I'm worried about splitting the wood you
know I don't I really don't want it weak
in the wood at all
this thing is just awesome I mean it is
rock solid on both ends
and you've got a very well balanced
javelin on one side and then you've got
this blade for slashing and stabbing on
this end it also acts like fletching on
an arrow so when you throw it this helps
keep it straight see it's awesome okay
it's the middle of the night it's pitch
black I gotta go throw this thing at
least once all right
you can't do a video about making an
African hunting spear without throwing
it at something so we have pucky the
deer here and he's gonna help us demo
this spear see how hard I can throw this
thing okay jackets coming off
[Music]
all right so there we go whoo that went
about that deep
right in the vitals Oh
[Music]
oh my gosh oh look at this it broke off
so what happened with this is this this
part of the spear is not meant for
throwing it's for slashing and stabbing
and that force of hitting it sideways
was too much and just broke off broke
off the wood now a couple of things that
I could have done different if I had
have made a cup mount instead of a Tang
it probably wouldn't have broken off but
I didn't okay another thing I could have
done is reinforced this with with some
sinew or some steel wire or something
like that and that would have reinforced
it as well so that's how the cookie
crumbles but there you go thanks for
watching hopefully you guys had as much
fun watching this video as we did making
it and if you want to see more great
videos from the outdoor boys YouTube
channel don't forget to yeah